business is brisk but this business is
smuggling doors windows bags of flour
bottles of milk all are being smuggled
over to Zimbabwe in defiance of tough
new import laws imposed by Robert
Mugabe's government the smugglers don't
fear much some are a little shy because
of the camera but they're staggeringly
confident that their illegal activities
will go ahead unhindered
I'm not comfortable revealing our
relationships with the authorities
around here you know in case I injure
them but we do work with them and they
cooperate and by working with them he
means bribing everyone gets a cut to
look the other way this is what used to
be the Limpopo River which divides the
two countries now a dusty road which
stretches for miles a dry season on the
back of a drought has created an open
passageway where smugglers can
crisscross freely this dried-up riverbed
means the crossing between Zimbabwe and
South Africa has never been easier and
this is open day and night we're told
that at the moment up to 500 people
every day are crossing from Zimbabwe
into South Africa high unemployment in
Zimbabwe means most commodities inside
the country are unattainable for many so
it's not only goods which are being
smuggled in and out it's people too many
Zimbabweans don't have passports so
cross illegally into South Africa to
find work they've each paid smugglers to
bring them to Johannesburg the City of
Gold where they hope to get a better
life
they've been taken to the huge sprawling
Township that is deep Sloot where they
said they were held in shacks by the
smugglers who demanded a fee for their
release then if you call that person if
that person didn't come they keep you
know stitch and then are they gonna tell
you that if maybe we're gonna give you
today's if that person didn't come on
that today's they will tell you that
maybe they will give you little fun
email for you they use your sometimes I
mean the rape here yes Joyce was held
for three weeks and repeatedly raped
until a stranger bought her from her
captors there was just between us always
or sometimes the Irate does that have
been pushed us to come outside do you
need something to to sleep with us so
that they we think what I didn't take
that language to pay they are appreciate
from those guys I kept them there man
how much money 1500 and this is never
if it is about market again come with
baby do you feel safe
take care of me make sure that I eat
every day the sleep eat everything
except that my husband my future husband
but even though if I just love because
of the situation that I believe that in
me and he I can build that love you say
you wanted to help her do you ever think
that maybe you're also using her yes I
know that may I may be using me at some
times I'm not forcing you to do that
sometimes you're not forcing her and it
should never turn I'm not much for
trusting you to do that we do things in
England whatever the agreement this was
not the new life Joyce and village when
she fled Zimbabwe Alex Crawford Sky News
Johannesburg